هدف امريكي جديد في مرمى الصين اتفاق امني
بين باب وغينيا الجديده واشنطن قد يكبل
النفوذ الصينيه في المحيط الهادئ هذا
الاتفاق يتيح للقوات الامريكيه الوصول الى
موانئ ومطارات باب وغينيا البعيده عن
الصين بسته
الاف257 كيلو مترا المسافه ليست قريبه لكن
الدوله تعد في قلب المجال الحيوي للتنين
الاسيوي في المحيط الهادئ
شراكه امريكيه جديده تاتي امتدادا لوثيقه
شراكه سابقه مع دول جزر الهادئ وقادتها
البالغه عددهم 14
واشنطن اكدت التزامها تقديم حوافز
دبلوماسيه وماليه مقابل الدعم الاستراتيجي
ومواجهه التحديات المتزايده في منطقه
الهادئ وهي تشكل اهميه جيوسياسيه بالنسبه
للامن القومي لواشنطن بحسب الخبراء
بكين كانت قد استفادت في السابق من فراغ
امريكي في المنطقه لكن الطبيعه لا تحتمل
الفراغ ولا التوازنات الدوليه على ما يبدو
الصين سيطرت على المناجم والموانئ بموجب
اتفاقيه امنيه غامضه مع جزر سليمان في
ابريل الماضي نفس الاتفاقيه تسمح للصين
بنشر قواتها في البلاد مما عززها واجس
شركاء واشنطن في المنطقه لا سيما استراليا
ونيوزيلندا تجاذبات في مشهد الصراع
الامريكي الصيني وسط توقعات باستداد
التنافس على النفوذ في المنطقه لكن فعاليه
الشراكه الامريكيه مع دول محيط الهادئ
تبقى مرهونه باداره التباين بين اولويات
الطرفين فاولويه دول الهادئ تنمويه
واقتصاديه واولويات واشنطن امنيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات